mitch mcconnell líder del partido
republicano en el senado dijo ayer que
la votación y el debate sobre el
impeachment aprobado por la cámara de
representantes- empezarán una vez
instale el nuevo gobierno de joe biden
en la casa blanca el 20 de enero eso
quiere decir que trump terminara su
mandato y que el impeachment es y es
aprobado pues se hará una vez deje la
casa blanca los demócratas tras la
votación especial de georgia lograron
las mismas 50 sillas que tienen los
republicanos en el senado y esto les da
mayoría porque el voto de desempate lo
tiene la nueva vicepresidenta kamala
harris sin embargo para que el
impeachment sea aprobado se necesitan
dos tercios del senado algo que según
analistas puede ser difícil de lograr a
pesar de las críticas de los propios
republicanos tanto en el congreso como
la cámara de representantes sin embargo
lo que dicen también analistas es que si
se podría alcanzar esa cifra de 67 votos
para aprobar el impeachment en el senado
porque ya hay algunos republicanos que
actuarían de forma más libre sin trump
en la casablanca aplazada en todo caso
la votación hasta después de la posesión
evita cualquier
que desmán a cualquier violencia en
washington derivada de cualquier
decisión política y es que los
simpatizantes de donald trump tienen
agendada ya una marcha en la capital el
17 de enero la llamada misión militar
march también sería el 20 de enero día
de la posesión hay que mencionar que el
18 el lunes también será acá en
washington celebrada pues el día de
honor a martin luther king y habrán
grandes manifestaciones de ciudadanos
afroamericanos y activistas en la ciudad